coup de coeur du cinéma les yeux d'elsa
cette semaine c'est le festival les yeux
pleins d'étoilés puisque c'est notre
sixième édition est une édition placée
sous le signe de la famille donc puisque
c'est un événement familial y en a pour
tous les goûts tous les âges
alors ça commence avec un événement
inédit dimanche une avant-première du
grand méchant renard le film de benjamin
renner qui avait réalisé un essai
célestine en partenariat avec
l'association contrechamp est ce que
quelqu'un peut récupérer michel je m'en
occupe si tu veux ça ne me dérange pas
du tout non mais ça va pas plaire
samedi 17 juin une journée autour des
familles fantastique avec notamment un
ciné continue pour les petits à partir
de 2 ans à 10 heures avec la conteuse
charlotte gillot et puis pour terminer
ponyo sur la falaise le dimanche 18 à 16
heures avec un ciné goûter projection
départementale voilà vous pouvez
retrouver le programme de notre festival
sur le site de la ville de saint cyr
l'école et à bientôt j'espère